and this is my thing from the beginning
it's the children it's the N 8 to 9,000
children and this is the misconception a
lot of people out there talk does this
fit into that description the what's the
definition of terrorism it is the
purposeful killing of innocent civilians
despite being Jewish I've been anti you
know what Israel wants they want them to
be Dubai go be the Dubai of the
Mediterranean we wish you luck it's
hilarious it it honestly it could be
hilarious it could be a comedy sketch
what he's saying says as a Jew I've been
to many Holocaust Museum locked the rest
of you in the basement and said we'll
control your water your food we won't
let you out greetings and peace my next
guest Lee Camp is one of the most
censored comedians in America writer
podcaster news journalist news
commentator and he's also Jewish and
what fascinated me about him was one of
his earlier tweets that I read and I'm
going to go ahead and read it to you
before we bring him out Lee Camp says as
a Jew I've been to many Holocaust
museums they often have a pile of shoes
or clothing of those who are killed it's
painful to see it's moving one day there
will be a museum to remind us of all the
genocide that's been being perpetuated
against Palestinians it's very well
might have a pile of thousands of
children's
shoes will you be able to say you did
what you could to stop this massacre
ladies and
gentlemen I love
you when was ready talk about it I would
only talk to I was explaining how much
respect I have for the faith of
Islam to the de show the de
show Lee Camp thanks for having me how
you doing my friend how are you I'm all
right certainly can't complain
considering the tragedies that are going
on around the world let's start off
before I play this clip and I want to
get your reaction to it what got you
into this what got you just you know
instead of U like many people you
covered where you even have uh
celebrities they get paid off uh
supporting this kind of stuff you know
people are just busy and hustle bustle
of day-to-day life and they don't want
to get cancelled they're scared to go
against the norm what did it for you
that you're speaking up on the side of
uh your on
Humanity uh thanks for asking yeah I for
those who don't know me you you did
mention at the beginning that I'm the
most or one of the most censored
comedians in America uh but I'm more
than a comedian I've been a political
commentator for years now I wrote hosted
and and co-created a comedy news show
that got very popular called redacted
tonight it was on RT America uh that was
shut down the entire channel was shut
down two years ago due to us sanctions
um but since then and and even before
that I've been censored and suppressed
on many different channels and platforms
Shadow band on Facebook I had my YouTube
channel of a quarter million subscribers
banned around the world and many people
may hear that and they may think oh he's
a you know far right winger to to be
that banned and suppressed but no they
do it against Real left Wingers as well
real leftists who actually stand for
peace and sustainability and and those
are the things I'm fighting for and it
it has made me incredibly suppressed
censored and the like um but like you
mentioned I I'm I do more than just
comedy I've I've been doing political
comedy for years but now especially in
the past couple years my live streams
which I do four days a week have very
little comedy in them because the the
truth just seems too important to to
pause and and make the jokes um and and
you know I I feel like I'm doing
something important so it doesn't bug me
that much that I am not doing as much
comedy but uh these are incredibly
critical times I've been despite being
Jewish I've been anti Zionist for years
now uh but I did grow up you kind of
grow up as a Jew in America just
thinking that Judaism equals Israel and
that is not true there are many millions
of anti-zionist Jews around the world
there are also more Zionist Christians
in the United States than there are Jews
in the world so the Zionist experiment
the apartheid state of Israel is
actually more supported by Christians
than it is by Jews and most people never
talk about that aspect of it is that uh
the uh Network you were on the TV
program was that with Abby Martin yeah
she actually I first started appearing
on her show art on RT America before I
ever had a show and they saw me on her
show and then gave me my own comedy show
um and I was with her at RT America for
about a year before she uh moved to do
other things but uh still good friends
with her she's
amazing yeah tar said hello I've had her
on the program also all right let's go
ahead let's go ahead and get your uh
reaction to uh this clip here from the
pbd podcast I cannot remind you enough
how many times Israel has tried to
compromise with a two-state solution so
let me just read the facts cuz I don't
speak on a motion 1936 appeal commission
Israel accepted Palestinians rejected
1947 un partition plan rejected and then
the Arab leagues waged a war the next
day that led to the alleged nakba of
displacement because they said get out
of here let's kill all the Jews and
you'll take the land back the next day
1967 cartoon resolution rejected by the
Palestinians 2000 Camp David Summit
Arafat and AUD Barack rejected by the
Palestinians 2005 we tried to compromise
Israel withdrew from Gaza could have
been the biggest beautiful Resort on the
beach and the best piece of land that
they had to offer instead they turned it
into a terrorism Haven so we often hear
this that um this pushed out there that
uh they've always wanted peace and how
you going to have peace when they keep
rejecting
peace yeah it's of course laughable um
and I don't I don't think getting bogged
down in the in the nitty-gritty of
exactly what was in each different uh uh
possible agreement I don't generally
think that's of much use because if you
look at the overall structure of this
the overall structure of these
agreements it is as if someone you know
came into your house killed a couple of
your family members locked the rest of
you in the basement and said we'll
control your water your food we won't
let you out but here's an agreement you
get to govern yourself and you can do
whatever you want as long as you remain
in the basement and then you being in
the basement with a couple of dead
family members says you know I'm not
going to agree to that and now you're
the person who turned down peace so it's
a it's a laughable you know uh
propagandist Viewpoint to begin with to
even uh go through that stuff but many
of the times you know if you get into
the nitty-gritty many of the times it's
Israel that actually blew up the peace
process the whole idea of the two-state
solution is useful to Israel because
they can keep finding reasons to never
let it happen because the truth is the
truth that they don't want to reveal is
they will never allow a Palestinian
State because they view it as an
existential threat if you allow a
Palestinian State then that state has
certain rights such as to actually be
represented at the UN or to have a
military uh or to have access to their
own your own water and food and to be
able to leave and come you know come and
go from your country as you see fit all
of those things Israel does not want to
allow so when Israel says when people
various people or various Israelis say
they want a two-state solution they
actually do not they just know that
saying that makes it seem like they want
peace let's go into this next clip and I
think this is uh one of the people on
the panelist Vinnie met him seemed like
a nice man and he's thinking uh he he's
one who his human Humanity seems like
it's it's still uh there and he's
raising some really good points so get
your feedback on this there's no winning
in this situation but it's and this is
my thing from the beginning it's the
children it's the N 8 to 9,000 children
and this is the misconception a lot of
people out there talk you can be
Pro Palestinian kids not dying and not
be a supporter of Hamas that drives
me bananas cuz I see people saying that
stuff if you care about the kids you
support Hamas there has to be a tactical
shift where it's not just bomb bomb bomb
bomb bomb because we got to get rid of
Hamas that's my attitude yeah so he's uh
talking about the kids I mean we're
seeing what is it a population of 2.3
half of which are un under 18 children
and they're just being uh massacred
their heads are actually coming off from
these um bombs and he's speaking
logically um what do you think from what
he was talking about yeah he's he's
making a fine point uh I I unfortunately
watched this full video of uh the the
Israeli propagandist woman there uh the
blond haired woman and she goes on after
he says that she she go she kind of for
a second says I agree with you but then
immediately Dodges to how horrible
Israelis have it or something like that
so she actually does not want to talk or
think or even for a moment think about
the number sheer insane numbers of
children that are being murdered daily
by the Israel bombing I mean they've
dropped enough bombs to equal two atomic
bombs the size of hirosima they have
killed as we know over 20,000 people 70%
of those are women and children and that
doesn't even count the innocent men that
they're also killing um but so he he
says that and there's very little or I
watched most of the video I didn't watch
all of it there's very little push back
from the hosts now that may be the style
of their show that they just let someone
speak uh but they let uh her for the
most part just spout the this complete
garbage propaganda about Israel uh
endlessly and they don't really push
back from it and you mention the the
kids are being beheaded and killed by
bombs you mention that point and earlier
in the interview I think or later um the
other host uh when she says well let's
remember Israelis are not beheading
anyone Israelis are not uh doing that
type of violence and the host goes
absolutely agreeing now of course they
are what's the difference whether a kid
and the whole Hamas beheaded babies we
found out is completely debunked but
besides that point uh what's the
difference between beheading a baby and
dropping bombs that behead babies the
only difference is that it allows you a
slight level of distance so you can say
oh we didn't mean to but we all know
after three months after killing over
20,000 people after having a rate of
child murder per bomb that is far higher
than any other Modern War we've seen in
Generations or decades uh we know
they're intentionally doing this we know
this is the goal of Israel in most
modern warfare nowadays the number of
children killed by bombs is like six to
eight perent children in Gaza it's 40
some percent are children wow uh 43 or
45% so Israel knows what they're doing
the idea that they don't know they're
murdering children is laughable so she
says oh Israel Israelis Israel is not
doing that type of thing yeah they are
they absolutely are so it's just
ridiculous yeah you've seen I mean
you've probably seen most of the footage
where you have a father or you have a
mother they're literally picking up body
parts yeah so there'll be an arm here a
leg here a head here so uh this is false
to say that that they're not taking off
heads but they they actually are you
know with from the sky from these bombs
from and and Israel yes and Israel
absolutely knew what they were doing by
cutting off all resources to the
hospitals cutting off the electricity
the hospitals you know we've heard this
propaganda talking point at various
times over the many decades uh of a a
military force killing babies it was
used to invade Iraq back in the first
Gulf War against Kuwait uh the killing
babies thing the Hamas they accused
Hamas of it on October 7th without any
evidence and and so it's used as
propaganda but it's actually true when
it comes to Israel because literally
they cut off the electricity to
incubators and we see that those
children have died a thousands of babies
in these hospitals have died and again
Israel knows what they're doing they
they are not striking hospitals
accidentally the reason they're doing
that is because they want to create a
Health crisis in Gaza even the UN has
said half of all gazin are are at risk
of dying of starvation and disease May
ultimately kill more Gins than bombs and
that again is Israel's strategy if they
can destroy the health systems then they
can actually kill more Gins with
disease is that the definition of
terrorism um I'm going to let one of the
co-hosts he defines what terrorism this
does this fit into that description the
what's the definition of terrorism it is
the purposeful killing of innocent
civilians for political agenda for any
agenda and it's such a way to create
fear of other things happening so what's
my why is it I mean I don't have a
problem I mean you know you're Jewish
I'm Muslim we're coming together it's
beautiful to see and as a Muslim if
something's confirmed that they are
innocent this is something um just clear
I mean you you cannot Target innocent
men women CH we I we don't have a pro I
don't have a problem if if something's
confirmed that intentionally men women
children are Target we'll condemn this
but why is it if you'll ask someone like
this do you condemn this IDF are they
doing terrorism it's like very you you
you'll never get someone to condemn that
and call it terrorism because in their
view they to do the propaganda the hbar
they feel they can never admit that
they've targeted civilians so instead
they act like they haven't but we know
they've targeted civilians these are not
just accidental strikes uh we know that
they have called journalists and said
we're going to strike you and the reason
they do that is because some of the time
they've asked the journalist who lead
crowded areas so they can kill them um
as with
Dr
rafit arel what was his name um anyway
uh rafat uh but he was told to leave the
the refugee area he was in if he didn't
want that whole area destroyed which is
an admission that they are targeting a
civilian journalist academic so we know
they're targeting civilians it's not
even a question but they keep denying
that uh and so they won't admit that
they won't admit it's terrorism but it
clearly is although actually as I say
that in many ways they have admitted
those things uh you know because we have
seen Israeli cabinet ministers say that
no one in Gaza is innocent well meaning
they can bomb anyone well that's an
admission of war crimes because bombing
children is a war crime bombing
civilians that are not connected to
military are is a war crime so saying
there are no innoc collected what
Collective punishment what is it called
punishment yeah absolutely these are
these are war crimes and it's it's
ethnic cleansing it's genocide if you
look at the definition of genocide at on
the Holocaust Memorial funds website
which they're getting it from the UN as
well but you look on their website and
every single box will be ticked as to
this as to proof this is genocide and
the only thing that that they could
argue uh that they try and argue is you
have to have intention you have to do
these things in intentionally well many
of them have said that there's no
innocence in Gaza many of them have
called these nonhuman they've called
them beasts and things like that to
allow ethnic cleansing and let's
remember just days before October 7th uh
Netanyahu got up in front of the UN and
held up a map of the Middle East with
Gaza and the West Bank erased gone and
so this is their goal is to erase the
Palestinian people from Gaza it's it's
so clear they've I mean they've really
admitted it what do you think when you
hear statements like this you know what
Israel wants they want them to be Dubai
go be the Dubai of the Mediterranean we
wish you luck we want GDP we want
happiness we want success we want much n
for you a trading partner we want we
want exactly and that you know who will
benefit from that the Palestinian people
when you hear that as someone who
doesn't have much knowledge like
yourself you know just the average
person he's hearing that he's like
what's wrong with these people they love
for them to prosper to be like Dubai
it's like what what is is wrong with
these people are they insane are they
crazy uh but what what are your comments
someone who's an expert in this someone
who's been covering this for years
hilarious it it honestly it could be
it's hilarious it could be a comedy
sketch what he's saying like you could
have an audience sitting there laughing
and it would be a great comedy sketch
you go in you you notice he keeps doing
this hand motion pushing outward because
they went in and pushed everyone out of
their you know ancestral lands kicked
them out and put the Rel the Gins into
an open air prison where they don't have
access to so when they keep saying oh
become the Dubai of the mediteran they
don't have access to materials to often
do enough food to clean water uh there
are so many reasons they cannot quote
unquote be the Dubai of that area it's
so laughable they're not even allowed to
their own fish they're not allowed to go
fishing Beyond a mile outside of the of
the waters there uh Israel has destroyed
their a airport so they can't have
people or things flown in Israel has
destroyed their port so they can't have
boats arrive let's remember the the
freedom flotilla tried to get to Gaza to
bring medication this is years ago like
2014 or something and IDF troops and
from helicopters landed on the boat and
killed one of the unarmed activists so
that is what they get when they try and
do anything bring in materials or
anything else Israel has them in a
prison and so the idea it'd be like
looking at it people locked up in an
American Asylum a prison and saying why
aren't you guys building Wall Street
here why aren't you guys building the
massive skyscrapers oh maybe it's
because they're locked up in prison it
is so laughably insane and I mean it's
sad that anyone can hear what he just
said and think that that makes any sense
at all I want to show you this next clip
it's regarding L beer he's uh from the
one of the disaster relief organizations
his of which raised close to uh $50
million I want to get you a reaction to
this because you've covered a lot of
different things like the handleable
directive I think I you were the one of
the firsts I heard this from uh and then
get your reaction for example Eli beer
the president of United hatzalah went on
a media tour around the United States
telling audiences that babies were
placed in ovens and baked to death a
little baby in an oven they put him in
the bastards put these babies in an oven
and put on the oven we found the kid a
few hours later this propelled him and
his organization to the Forefront of the
media for several days earning tons of
awareness for his organization's work he
was able to leverage this media
attention into several fundraisers where
he managed to collect a whopping $50
million from shocked and appalled donors
but of course the entire story was a lie
Israeli reporter Isa Cohen investigated
and determined that the story wasn't
true another Israeli journalist Kim
Lenin said had this to say about Eli
beer and the of inory like any
good Jew who sees the rich he thought
about the money and told a story that
does not exists but this lie not only
raised a ton of money for Eli beer it
did considerable now is this just a
conspiracy theory or is there any truth
to this have you covered anything like
this do you know about this story so I
haven't covered the specific uh the
organizations charitable organizations
or whatever they are but in terms of the
killing of of children and look I I am
opposed to war I'm opposed to killing
I'm opposed to hostages so I don't
support if if Hamas just shot innocent
people that weren't IDF fighting with
them then I'm opposed to that but
absolutely but in terms of the the
evidence we've seen a large number a
large percentage and we'll probably
never know the actual percentage of
those killed on October 7th were killed
by the IDF in crossfire and you
mentioned the Hannibal directive this is
a now fairly well-known directive
although they didn't want it to be
wellknown of the IDF of the Israeli
government that if someone is taking
hostages you kill everyone you kill the
hostage you hostages you kill the people
taking them and you kill anyone around
because the idea their their conceptual
idea is that it is useful it is more
useful to not have a hostage and to just
kill everyone around than to try try and
uh you know deal with the hostage
negotiations so they first did this
years ago and came up with this
directive and we saw it on October 7th
which actually lasted through about
October 9th uh where they arrived in
tanks and we now have seen video of
Tanks just shelling uh civilian uh
facilities civilian houses that where
Hamas had hostages and I think Hamas
thought that those of them holding
hostages thought they would be allowed
to return to Gaza with a certain number
of hostages uh if they you know that
Israel would make a deal with them but
instead Israel showed up the IDF showed
up and just blew up these facilities
Burning uh everyone inside in many cases
and so the babies they found that have
been burned were burned by the IDF uh
and another another example of this is
we've actually seen an interview with
some of the tank Gunners it was actually
supposed to be a pro-israel interview it
was of the Fe fale tank Gunner uh group
so it was kind of these hero females
from the Israeli perspective that were
and you know they're 20 year olds 21
year olds and they talk about how they
were driving these tanks and they didn't
really know what they were doing and
then they got to the place where the
hostages were being held and she says
she was told to fire on the building and
she turned to her commanding officer and
said aren't there civilians in there and
he said I don't know just fire and she
says I decided not to fire the tank uh
shells because there's civilians in
there but I fired my gun so they were
firing on civilian structures and they
knew it and that is why we saw so many
hundreds killed on October 7th when
hamas's plan was to take hostages we've
seen a lot what I've just analyzing all
of this and just getting more and more
more educated when this when this uh
comes up um uh is that the zionists here
they usually have a script and they go
off many of these uh talking points like
the one that uh you just uh refuted
there a lot of these things it takes a
little bit more investigation someone to
come in look at and look at the other
side because i' I've seen that they're
notorious for half truths I call them
Spin Doctors sometimes just outright
lies things that are out of context I'm
going to give one example and this is
one one of the one of the people that's
uh debated um many who are out there and
he just gets called out many times they
don't get called out but I want to
commend this news commentator that she
actually calls him out okay so do you
have evidence you've seen a sign of a
Jewish voice for peace member holding a
sign that says clean Palestine of dirty
Jews that's a pretty remarkable sign
that I feel like would have gone quite
viral if someone had some evidence of
that say clean clean is a Nazi term that
was used in the 1930s and 40s to refer
to dirty Jews Palestine will be free
from the river so you're saying you did
not see a sign that said clean Palestine
of dirty Jews you're saying that you saw
a sign with the word clean and you're
reading into that of course I'm reading
into it wouldn't you I see yeah so in
this situation um certain things are put
out there like he did saying that
someone was uh they had signs is
actually that it was Jews for peace Jews
voice for peace have you heard this of
this
organization and he was trying to yeah
go ahead yeah Jewish voice for pce to
great work uh so that's Alan
DST a a pathetic human being who is you
know a propagandist for Israel and uh
propagandist for other horrible things
such as Jeffrey Epstein but uh he uh
he's arguing with Briana Joy gray she
does great work and yeah he's he said he
said himself she got him to admit
himself that he's reading into a sign uh
that that he saw but I always like to
get past these so let's say someone did
see a sign that said something
completely anti-semitic you know get rid
of the Jews or something like that well
okay that's an anotal example of an
idiot of an anti-semitic idiot it
doesn't mean those don't exist I'm sure
those people exist in this world and
they probably have markers and they
probably make a sign sometimes but that
does not justify genocide that Israel is
perpetrating it doesn't justify anything
it it it is an anecdotal who is
anti-Semitic and in terms of the
anti-Semitism which you know one of
Israel's greatest tactics with the yous
for decades is to accuse anyone is
critical of Israel of being anti-semitic
I mean hell they even will call Jewish
people like me who are anti-zionists
anti-semitic which again is laughable
but uh so that's their their thing is
they'll call anyone criticizes Israel
anti-semitic but in fact they are the
ones making anti-Semitism in this world
worse because if you commit genocide and
conflate and they intentionally conflate
Israel with all Jews or Zionism with all
Jews which it is not these are two
different things yes it is a Jewish
state but there are millions of Jews
around the world who do not support
Israel's actions Israel is an apartheid
state Israel's genocide they're
perpetrating right now so Israel
intentionally conflates Judaism with
Zionism and then this increases
anti-Semitism it confuses lowi
information people and they think that
all Jews are committing this genocide
when that is 100% not the
case uh this next clip is from a rabbi
David I had him on the program early I
want this to hit home when you mentioned
our part tide uh racism this is
something now that people who say okay
this is the only democracy in the Middle
East what and whatever all the other you
know Disney like things that are
portrayed with it this is actually a
rabbi who went out and and he had his
first instance and what he of something
opposite to that and led him into a
state of cognitive dissonance let's take
a look at this clip and get your
reaction to it and then for people to
really uh understand what they're
supporting I first went to Israel as a
19-year-old young man trying to find my
place in the world coming to a place
where I felt like whoa you know like
Israel that's that's like my people's
country very first week maybe the second
or third day I would say in Jerusalem I
was walking down a street that's called
Jaffa Street it goes from the Jaffa gate
to Jaffa and there's nice Old Stone
shops and stuff and there was a little
boy maybe six or seven year- old boy
bleeding from his head he must have cut
his hand on a broken bottle bleeding and
crying and and and there was two
policemen there so I I went to the boy
and I said you know come with me and I
took him to the policeman and I said
said to the policeman in Hebrew help
help this boy and they said to me what
are you talking about he's an Arab you
know just get rid of him so that was my
first
experience I have you seen things like
this uh I mean you know the videos go
around I've been to Israel twice uh once
have you being to Israel have you have
you experienced have you have any
stories like this well uh not not
specifically like that but what I do
have is so I went I went twice I went as
a teenager when before I had understood
what Israel was the apartheid state
everything else and was that the right
of return trip yeah then I did the
birthright trip when I was 2 when I was
26 and I did understand what I was
dealing with I did understand that
Israel was an apartheid state oppressing
uh Arab people and um so I went with
open eyes that time and the reason I
went was because I figured well I I want
to see the reality and the truth is you
go on one of those trips because it is
funded by Israel and it is a a
propaganda showcase I mean it is the
highest level of manipulation and
propaganda you spend time with the IDF
uh many of the many of the young men end
up hooking up with women in the IDF uh
you they they use sleep deprivation you
arrive jet lagged and they allow you two
hours of sleep and then they get you up
and force you to move on so you are
delirious uh they use every every
manipulation trip in the book to get you
obsessed with Israel or really endorsing
Israel uh hilariously we my group ended
up being used for propaganda because
they saw us sitting in a circle writing
in notebooks and they used that photo on
the cover of the uh main Israeli
newspaper saying we were writing you
know love letters to the prime minister
or something so uh it's just a parade of
propaganda it's just really impressive
the amount of ipulation and propaganda
that that I saw uh I didn't actually
witness abuse of Arabs but you know
that's because they try and hide that
thing that that stuff last question is
um when the question is asked why have
so many celebrities politician
influencers Express strong support of
Israel and you give an answer to this
why is that yeah I just did a an eight
minute video from breakthrough news I
hope people will check it out but uh so
many and now look many of the celeb
lities it is it is genuine uh they don't
understand what they're talking about
many of them they are Jewish and much
like I grew up in my early years they
think that Jewish people just support
Israel quote unquote and that's the end
of the equation they don't look into the
reality uh so there is some of that but
in terms of these influencers many of
the influencers it's been it's been
reported you can find articles many of
the influencers were paid $5,000 after
October 7th to make one video saying
they support Israel $5,000 for your
average influenc or or really your
average human on this planet is a ton of
money and so to be offered that much
money uh is just unbelievable then you
have many of these uh pro-israel
protests where publicly we've seen
offers of $250 per college student to
show up at the one in Washington DC uh
that is a lot of money to a college
student so it is tough to know the
number of people that have been paid to
make these statements and to be involved
in this uh but it is clearly a lot the
amount of money that is dumped into uh
creating support for apartheid and
support for genocide is clearly a lot uh
and then you have a a congress well he's
running for congress uh in Michigan and
he made a video you can go watch it I
think his last name is Nasser maybe uh
he was offered $20 million to drop out
of the senate race and run in the house
against Rashida Talib because she is the
only palestinian-american in Congress
and she is the only one fully standing
up for Palestinians in Congress and he
was offered 20 million doar I mean
unbelievable amount of monies amount of
money to manipulate the sentiment and
the the talking points and the faces
that are endorsing
genocide last last question Lee Camp uh
tell us uh what would you what advice
would you give for someone who's just
their Humanity's on and they're not
liking what they're seeing you know
they've been programmed over the years
they watch a lot of mainstream media
media working they go ahead and follow
some of your work and so they don't have
to go through a long straight of
cognitive dissidence you know how how
should they look more into this to to
view this properly the way that so they
can get the the truth I really
appreciate that uh number one step
number one is turn off mainstream media
it's even if you think you're seeing
through some of the manipulation you're
probably not seeing through all of it
you you people who leave it on are
heavily manipulated I spent my early 20s
leaving it on in the background thinking
I was somehow learning something you're
learning nothing you're you're just
accepting garbage into your head it just
it just takes a big giant dump in your
brain is what it does so that's step one
in terms of my stuff my the easiest way
to find my stuff is Lee camp.com LEC
mp.com but like I said I started a new
show with breakthrough news I hope
people will check that out and uh I'm on
rumble.com lecamp as well but uh in
terms of finding people people other
people that are doing great work um you
know there's a whole long list of
awesome people that I could give but I
will say many of them are at the media
aggregate site rad
media.com uh r a d n d iia.com i created
it but it it makes no money there's no
pay walls it's just designed to show
people uh news outside of the mainstream
media so you know I I do promote it
because I think people need to wake up
but I get essential no money from it uh
it just loses money but I did it anyway
so with Elanor Goldfield so rad Indy
media.com thank you for speaking out
thank you thank
you I'm Dr and I'm so excited to be here
at the dean Center Mah which is under
renovation and I can't wait to see
what's going to come inshah there's
going to be a dawa Center there's a
Masjid there's a school an Islamic
school a gym and what we hope inshah
we'll also have a mental health part of
this Center as well in
so I'm asking you to please make sure
that you support this effort inshallah I
really hope that it spreads and really
the knowledge of Islam and people get to
know more about Muslims and Islam
through this
[Music]
effort I cannot leave without giving you
a gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call US at800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam